okay so we'll we'll start the final talk
of the day we'll finish about 5 30 and
announce where the the beer calories and
the live oompah band as we can go get
some drinks and and then everyone has to
get not hungover for the talks which
will start at 9am tomorrow and so to
close off because we've only got the one
final talk now due to some schedule
rejigging we have Emma and Billy Emma
runs data kind UK and bitty volunteers
of the group I gotta be right yeah and
they're going to explain what they too
kind is all about and how we can all get
involved so please welcome Emma anybody
hi everyone thank you very much and so
out curiosity who has heard of data kind
that's really good okay so data kind
began in New York about four years ago
the general gist of what we do is
bringing data science to nonprofits so
we now have six chapters around the
world from San Francisco to Singapore I
run the UK group and so yeah the general
gist is on the one hand you have data
scientists with mad skills she learning
predictive modeling really impressive
and they are pretty much exclusively in
the private sector but we've tapped into
this amazing phenomena which is a lot of
them want to volunteer so on the other
hand we have charities who have a lot of
expertise and their particular issue
areas solving whatever social problem it
is and a lot of us sitting on
significant amounts of data so they will
have a database of every beneficiary
they've helped over 20 years but beyond
pulling out the odd number to try to a
funder they haven't really done that
much analysis on that data and so what
we do is kind of bring these two groups
together and we need Oh scope out and
manage projects for nonprofits using
volunteers we call them data ambassadors
so Billy was the data ambassador is
still data ambassador for us
and what I'm going to talk about today
is a specific project we ran with
Citizens Advice Bureau if anyone wants
to find out more about data card to come
and chat to me at the end of the talk so
citizens advice they began I think
that's right think they began First
World War um and the idea was they were
helping civilians who had problems like
their lost their ration booklet or they
wanted to locate someone and it was very
much kind of citizens helping other
citizens and it began as you can see in
kind of any makeshift place you could
find some army band they had and it is
now massive there are more Citizens
Advice Bureau shopfronts than there are
Tesco's in the UK there are over 3300 of
them and they help you working of all
all kinds of problems they help if you
have a problem with housing or
immigration legal matters consumer
issues whole array of issues and they're
dealing with a lot of people so this is
Obama's inauguration this is 1.8 million
people last year Citizens Advice so over
2 million people face to face in their
Bureau on top of these Bureau they also
have a hotline my people find up issues
they also have this advice guide oh
those photos in the shop and it's
whatever point is they're providing a
lot of services and a lot of different
ways to people all around the country
and they have their finger on the
country's pulse so to speak on the
issues of people are facing so what that
means for us is there's a ton of data so
every time someone goes into a bureau
with a problem it gets logged so they
have a lot of detail of the kinds of
people facing the kinds of issues in
different parts of the country from
these like face-to-face meetings they
have these texts forms which were a lot
of free text data that's staff in their
bureau whenever they want to flag a
particular problem filled in and this is
basically had never been looked at
troves and rows of text data unlined
they then had
the web data of people going on to their
websites and you know typing into
problems looking for advice on things
these three datasets were very siloed
they were doing you know they do quite a
lot they have a five or six person
information management teams they were
pulling out certain statistics using to
lobby governments but they didn't have a
comprehensive overview of what was going
on so the example they came to us with
was the payday loans issue a few years
ago whether anecdotally knew it was a
problem but they didn't realize the
scale and the result was they were quite
slow to respond so it took them some
like nine months to a year to actually
start lobbying government about this
issue because their data wasn't joined
up enough to realize how badly she was
so citizens advice came to data kind and
said good data science enable us to
anticipate or even predict changes in
issues affecting people every day so we
can act sooner to prevent these problems
and we thought hell yeah there's low
today are we can do the fancy piece of
modeling we got really excited and
Nestor funded us to put like to work on
the project for nine months it was
fantastic so the idea was on the one
hand try and build a tool or model for
systems advice helping spot new issues
on the other hand it was a kind of more
circus behavior change we were trying to
get in there and show them what was
possible new approaches new
methodologies other kinds of open data
trying it and sharing some of their data
just generally you know poking and
prodding up a bit and so it wasn't a
traditional project design we ran two
day to dive weekends which is like a
version of a hackathon so it's all that
kind of exploratory analysis we did one
long term piece of work with them to
kind of wrap up what was found at these
data dives that's what that theta core
is we had eight data ambassadors Billy
is one of them we had at least 50 day
scientists working on the project a ton
of pizza a ton of beer you know creative
chaos may
it was great but as happens with these
projects the kind of initial idea
involved a bit over the months he worked
with them so the idea of like a
predictive model to spot new issues
morphed a bit it was actually during the
second day to dive when we finally had
all their data in elastic search or
matched up and in Houston from pivotal I
produce this Cabana dashboard or 12
elasticsearch showing them just simply
pulling all this dream today to stick
together decide to show and compare who
is going for what issues using what
channel giving them this broad overview
in you know potentially it could be in
real time when they suddenly went holy
crap that's what we want screw the
predictive model even just bringing all
these pieces data together in a
dashboard that would revolutionize how
we work so that's what we did I'm not
actually here to talk to you today about
the dashboard I'm here to talk to you
about a side project we did that tags on
to the dashboard so while we you know
produce loads of beautiful graph to them
in the new version of Cabana and it all
looks very pretty and they're very
excited about it Billy had a bit of a
genius idea and he ran with it there's a
whole little side project to this which
I'm gonna let Billy explain to you guys
thanks Emma so actually I'm going to f1
side yep um this is the dashboard that
that was built and it's a really really
good dashboard to show citizens of ice
what issue people asking helpful so
maybe they may see a lot of people
asking for homelessness a lot of people
ask for help with food bank but what it
doesn't tell them is how these different
issues are related so other people who
ask for help with foot bank are the same
people who are asked for help with
homelessness if they are the same people
which one happens first if we know for
example people always ask for help with
a before they ask for help would be can
potentially we can do some preventive
advice and say well do you need help
with that as well then that can help
save citizens life money and also give
them better surface so that's the
motivation of what I try to do too
see if we can discover the relationships
up from the data about the different
kinds of issues that people as helpful
so just a little bit of visualization to
justify the work that I did this is an
analysis of the data from of a six month
period and these are they were the
different types of users and number of
times they have visited and this is the
percentage of usage by them so we can
see that about thirty percent of the
usage is by people who have visited
Citizens Advice Bureau Headley at least
twice so and this is just from a six
month period and so I'm sure if we have
a longer data from a longer duration we
will see more people who are multiple
users who are repeat users so that way
if we can reduce with repeated usage
then we can serve their clients better
and save money so if we try to model
that as a problem what does that
actually mean so I totally little bit
about it already we are basically trying
to say if a client has asked for help
with a is he more likely or less likely
to ask for help would be so
statistically mean I'm I feel like I'm
teaching the grandmother the subject I
mean it's basically just a calculating
lift so when we can't even lift it
basically just finding poverty a and B /
poor it publicly probability of a and
probably the probability of B so so far
so simple and then we can just count
those things and calculate and give an
estimate of these probabilities but of
course it's not quite as simple as that
for example if I have just one instance
out of two and it's that's quite a weak
piece of evidence but if I have 500
instances of a particular type of type
of people or people asking for help out
of well 1,000 then that is quite a quite
a much stronger piece of evidence so we
need to take that into account and
another thing that we need to take into
account is the temporal element so if
people ask for help with a and then
immediately immediately two weeks
afterwards they are
for help would be then intuitively we
would think that that's operate those
two things are quite strongly related
but if people if the the time spent
between these two issues is two years
then intuitively we think that maybe
they're actually not that strongly
related so we use a exponential decline
to dissimulate that idea so that gives
us a parameter to tune how how what is
our attention span do we want to look at
I mean issues that spend over long
period of time or do we just want to
look at things that are very tightly
wrong linked together in time wise Emma
talked about the elastic search and the
Cabana dashboard so that is a very big
and useful piece of deliverable for
citizens advice and the relationship
minor thing that I build fries on
basically the same infrastructure so
elastic search becomes the biggest
source that feeds both cabana and my
relationship my turn so how many of you
have you heard of spine yep so not not
many people how many of you have heard
of shiny you know yeah a lot more people
so basically its spire is the shiny for
Python it helps you mean just get your
graph out as a web application very
easily so if you haven't heard of it
before have a look at it it is great and
finally at the moment we have one static
data feed from citizens advice and once
this goes live then it will become a
regular data feed it would be all the
different types of data to Emma talk
about into elasticsearch okay enough
talking demo time right okay so let me
go back to you so we talked about the
different types of issues that people
talk people may ask helpful and in
citizens citizens advice they encode
those issues in a free tier level
so the here I'm allowing the users to
analyze based on where wished here how
granular they want to look at the issues
so let's look look at issue well at
level two first and then we can look at
the different issues from different
regions so let's pick the Northeast the
year at the moment we only have one
year's data so 2014 how many issues I
want to look at the half-life the the
perimeter digest talked about in terms
of our attention span so six months lift
1.2 that means we only want to plot that
relationship if a mix be at least twenty
percent more likely so let's have a look
so this is what what what it looks like
so so what does it actually tell us the
size of the bubble represents how how
frequently this issue happens in that
area so in the Northeast there were 150
thousand cases of people asking for help
and the second biggest issue looks like
council tax arrears are just around
11,000 and then the third one is a
personal independence payment and these
links represents the lift so the flicker
the line the stronger the relationship
so for example here we can see that
mortgage and secured long arrears is a
very strong predictor of the next one
which is bankruptcy so that that makes
that makes sense and cancel tech areas
is a big predictor for water supply and
sewage dance that's interesting okay now
there are a lot a lot of links in this
diagram so let's say we want to reduce
the number of links and we only lot more
significant ones so I'm only plotting
the links if they are at least forty
percent more likely so now it looks a
lot more manageable so now we can see
that mortgage is very strongly related
to bankrupt
and store card and critical and charge
cards are also very strongly related to
bankruptcy now one thing that's very
interesting is here we see people ask
for help with few first and then they
ask for help with field that and then
they ask for help with water supplies
something's not quite right if you don't
pay your gas bill the gas company can
cut you off but if you don't pay your
water bill the water company cannot cut
you off and cannot put send you into
jail so you should always pay one if you
if you're if you're running short of
money there's a certain party I mean
citizen advice should naturally not tell
people that don't pay this and don't pay
that I mean it's not in the business of
telling people I mean to get into that
but it will be very useful to tell them
for example well actually if you're
running sort of money there is I mean
that different consequences if you don't
pay your license a TV licence fee BBC
can put you in jail if you don't pay
your water bill the water bill the water
company cannot cut you off so these are
these are poor thing is that citizens of
ice can advise based on knowledge that
they discover here another thing that's
quite interesting is let's go back to
lift one point to another very
interesting thing is are they do these
things have regional variations I mean
different regions have different
economic situations and people people
may run into different problems so if i
look at london instead of the northeast
something very interesting happens right
ok the biggest bubble now is housing
benefit which is normally in london is
the most expensive market in terms of
housing so that so that makes sense but
one thing that we notice is there are
far fewer arrows on this chart then
compared with the northeast so one
hypothesis is well we know London it has
the highest concentration of charities
helping out people with different types
of issues so if people run into for
example let's say pension pension credit
issue they may ask citizen
vice for help but when they learn it's
another problem they may go for another
charity that specialized in that
particular issue so so that we can see
that that sort of relationship for
repeat clients asking for different help
the types of different issues is much
weaker in London so it's something that
maybe Citizens Advice can work with
other charities too so that I mean they
can form a full picture across these
issues and then one more I want to show
which is wails wails it's quite
interesting we know that in terms of
health outcome Wales is below the UK I
mean in terms of life expectancy in
terms of NHS performance in terms of
your other things so here we see that
disability is actually a bit an issue
but bigger issue here in Wales then
compared with for example when we saw in
in London or in the Northeast and here
also disability is disability disability
allowance is strongly linked to care
allowance so again this is something
that CA B can potentially intervene
early if somebody come and ask for help
with disability allowance maybe they can
proactively say well do you have a carer
is he getting the right support that he
needs so that immediately how we solve a
problem further down the line now before
I pass the mic back to Emma I just want
to show you one more thing here we also
what we're looking at here is the top 30
issues in Wales and and some of them may
have what some of them may have
relationship together but the things
that are most strongly related to for
example what we looked at money problem
that orders that relief orders may not
be within the top 30 issues so what we
can do next is to look at that issue in
particular so if we go to level two
issues and we just focus on one
particular issue so that relief order
and six months okay Wow okay so a lot of
links so let me customize that a bit
still a lot of links so then let's look
a lot shorter time frame okay so this is
a bit more manageable now so we can see
in London what is the strongest
predictor of people asking for help with
debt relief order so actually it's about
credit reference agency that is just
that is the strongest predictor aids the
link is thickest but there are also a
lot other things like building society
and overdraft and unsecured loans and a
few other things and if we push this
even further up then we can see this a
bit more clearly now so you may wonder I
mean if I have this information as
citizens advice what is going to what
what is it going to do I mean for me
that too well there are several things
that they can apply this one is to train
their advisors to be a more aware of the
cluster of issues that decline that
their clients experience so that I mean
the advice has become more effective the
other is also to structured organization
in such a way that these teams are
co-located together for example people
who deal with consumer debt and people
who deal with a utility that probably
did people different very different
people experience these issues so once
they discover the relationship and how
these really how these issues are club
cluster together then they can structure
their organization in such a way that it
becomes more effective in dealing with
their clients issue just one thing one
more thing sorry just one more thing
before I pass it back to you which is
true with all the things that you saw
was built with open source tools so this
is this being PI data of course it was
built in Python the spire I talked about
already so
once you have that graph of different
issues how they are linked together you
can analyze that with Network X which is
a fantastic library and the
visualization was done unfortunately in
JavaScript but I mean with inspire you
can integrate JavaScript quite easy as
well okay oh oh you use the e right and
so the main point of this app sitting
next to the dashboard is it gives
distance advice very much more holistic
over the other data and it gives them a
way to explore their hunches so
previously what was happening was that
star footprint this and this might be
connected and it's been emails
information management team you're three
days later service in the back small
spreadsheet and they'd have a look at it
see if they could find anything in there
um so this gives them the tools that
they can start looking at the data
themselves and they can start exploring
issues this which quite revolutionary
for the organization and it's still
being implemented so we're going to have
to wait that I think and see kind of the
longer term impact on what it all means
but in general everyone's very excited
about these new tools they've gone from
fairly static bar charts to you no more
interactive visualizations and they've
actually started opening up their data
so during the project sit-ins Advice
Bureau shared their data with some
mongers Broadway her a massive
homelessness charity and they linked up
data they've started talking about data
I hear much more regularly in meetings
they ran their own internal data dive a
couple months ago so they could start
kind of had a Friday they got all the
stuff together in a room anyone had any
knowledge of data and the organization
came together and they had their own
kind of exploratory analysis session and
so much more than just simply providing
you know a nap Anna dashboard I think we
slightly change their mindset which is
probably the most exciting bit about the
whole project and I think yeah I think
that's it
so we're happy to take questions if we
still have five minutes is there any
difficulty in getting data from the
charities like are there any legal
issues or previously issues like any
good bureaucracy there are always issues
so citizens advice I mean it's like 400
people in its HQ it has very stringent
data protection regulations it was a
slow process of hand-holding what was
quite interesting is that we were really
really sneaky so we went in it just said
all we could help you and reading the
back of our heads we were like and we
could get you to open up your danger too
we didn't tell them that just offer me
the first day to die with them we did
some great analysis for them we
shouldn't how great it could be we done
slowly sliding it and imagine if you
link to a date with another charity
imagine what that would be like yeah it
was it was a slow process a lot of
persuading a lot of non-disclosure
agreements signed by different parties
at different points yeah we all have to
sign NDA's to get the hands on the
Citizens Advice data um yeah but I
imagine it's the same in most sectors
so the question is one of the bubble was
children yeah it's just it just says
children um unfortunately we don't have
a representative from citizens advice
here they do the catalyzation so that
they'll be able to explain a lot more
than I could do I'm afraid sorry let's
thank